[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 et
sur Radio France Internationale nous
recevons aujourd'hui Martin Fayulu c'est
le président de l'engagement pour la
citoyenneté et le développement
en RDC bonjour Martin fayoulou bonjour
avec moi pour cette interview Christophe
Boisbouvier de RFI Martin Fayulu bonjour
bonjour
Martin Faya Yulu vous maintenez jusqu'à
ce jour avoir gagné la dernière élection
présidentielle vous êtes d'ores et déjà
candidats pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle prévue fin 2023 je
commençais cependant avec la situation
qui est grave on peut le dire dans l'Est
de la RDC on voit qu'il y a des
violences qui continuent les accusations
mutuelles d'escalade militaire entre la
RDC le Rwanda le président Tshisekedi à
la tribune des Nations Unies à dénoncé
sans détour l'agression militaire
directe du Rwanda les accords bilatéraux
ont été suspendus le président
Tshisekedi fait ce qu'il
l'agression de son ami son ami qui a
réussi à le placer au pouvoir monsieur
Kagame si monsieur Tshisekedi avait
refusé les dunes les dunes concocté par
Kagame et Kabila nous ne serons pas là
et si les Congo avaient respecté les
résultats des urnes la vérité des jeunes
aujourd'hui les Congo seraient gérés
différemment on n'aurait pas eu cette
guerre atroce que le Rwanda nous impose
mais il accuse Paul Kagame d'être de lui
avoir planter un couteau dans le dos de
trahison dorénavant c'est les chaussons
clairs quand même il me dit les choses
clairement il le dénonce mais dit des
choses clairement quand il me suit il
adopte maintenant mon langage le langage
que j'ai depuis des dizaines une dizaine
d'années que c'est Kagame qui est la
cause de nos malheurs et aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ne peut rien faire c'est ce
qu'on appelle la scissiparité ils sont
ensemble mais ils font
c'est que ce que le peuple dit parce que
le peuple ne veut pas de cette guerre le
peuple ne veut pas de cette agression le
peuple ne veut pas de cette violence et
Tshisekedi n'a pas d'autre choix que de
suivre le peuple alors de façon très
concrète est-ce qu'il faut rompre les
relations diplomatiques avec le Rwanda
ou non mais tout à fait la première
chose je l'ai dit et je le répète on
devait renvoyer l'ambassadeur rwandais à
Kinshasa et rappeler notre ambassadeur à
Kigali rompre les relations
diplomatiques portaient l'affaire à
l'Union africaine et aux Nations Unies
très clairement la solution qui est
prenait dans l'est de votre pays par la
communauté internationale et par Félix
Tshisekedi c'est le déploiement d'une
force de des pays d'Afrique de l'Est
notamment le Kenya le Burundi l'Ouganda
est-ce que ce ne serait pas quand même
une bonne solution non c'est pas une
bonne solution les Congo n'est pas dans
l'Afrique de l'Est et ça c'est Monsieur
Kagame qui a amené monsieur Félix
Tshisekedi dans cette affaire l'amour la
voir davantage pour balconiser
maintenant économiquement le Congo le
Rwanda ne serait pas dans cette force
multi
c'est le Rwanda qui dans le
renseignement vous savez bien que dans
les opérations militaires les
renseignements c'est la clé donc les
Ronda
donc pour nous ici en Afrique community
ce n'est pas notre affaire le Congo doit
renforcer son ami entraîner son armée
équipé son armée et avec la volonté des
Congolaises et des Congolais nous allons
gagner cette guerre et si nous voulons
un renfort c'est que nous devons nous
adresser au pays partenaires les vrais
du Congo pour
combattre l'agression mais en attendant
le renforcement des fr DC ça va prendre
deux ans trois ans on fait quoi en
attendant en attendant il faut demander
à Monsieur Kagame de retirer ses troupes
il faut demander à Monsieur mousse et
venir militairement comment vous allez
faire face à toutes ces armées venues au
Congo si vous n'avez pas pour l'instant
des alliés forts en dehors de ces pays
que sont le Kenya le Burundi et
l'Ouganda mais militairement monsieur
tshise
4 ans 4 ans on ne peut pas mettre en
place une armée équipée une armée
entraînée une armée qui peut combattre
c'est pas les militaires les vaillants
militaires qui manquent il y en a eu
mamadounda là était tué baouma a été tué
pourquoi et c'est depuis Kabila cette
agression ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
et cette agression c'est Kabila qui a
passé ça à Tshisekedi et donc voilà les
proxy des gens qui étaient gamins à
installer et ces gens-là sont des gens
qui mènent un complot contre les Congo
alors je vais en venir aux élections
elles sont prévues en théorie fin 2023
décembre 2023 et Félix Tshisekedi a dit
à France 24 et RFI un mois à New York
que le calendrier serait tenu malgré les
doutes par exemple du pneude mais
beaucoup de commentateurs disent
attention les conditions ne sont pas
réunies est-ce qu'il ne faut pas mieux
faire de bonnes élections propres
transparentes bien organisées en 2024
plutôt que des élections bâclées et
sujets à controverse en 2023 j'ai
entendu qu'il a dit qu'il y a pas de
calendrier et que les Canadiens
n'étaient pas important et ça ça me
donne que quelqu'un moderne qui planifie
des actions dit que les Canadiens
n'étaient pas importants mais les
calendrier doit être tenu c'est-à-dire
la date du des élections consignées par
la Constitution parce que la
Constitution de la République
démocratique du Congo est clair le
président de la République est élu au
suffrage et universel direct pour un
mandat de 5 ans 5 ans renouvelables une
seule fois cinq ans c'est pas 5 ans plus
une seconde donc il faut tenir c'est une
obligation
constitutionnel c'est un masque donc
maintenant si on va plus loin monsieur
Tshisekedi c'est lancé dans des
opérations de fraude le 17 juillet
2020 il met en place la Cour
constitutionnelle il nomme le membre de
la Cour constitutionnelle en violation
flagrante de la Constitution il se
prépare pour l'institution qui proclame
les résultats définitifs après il met en
place la CNI la commission électorale
tous ces gens à lui ou les gens qu'il a
débossé débauché il fait adopter au
Parlement une loi électorale en sa
faveur donc nous nous disons et
maintenant la CNI est entrée en fonction
depuis on ne fait rien il faudra
absolument avoir les élections
maintenant comme vous dites les experts
on dit que ce n'est pas possible d'avoir
des élections correctes des élections
impartiales
attends alors si c'est pas atteint vous
savez il y a un mot qui affectionne les
Congolais c'est les glissement quand
nous disons pas de glissement qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire mais je dis ce que dit
apprêter serment le 24 janvier 2019 cela
veut dire que le 23 janvier 2024 il doit
partir l'églisement c'est ça il part
mais maintenant si les experts nous
disent un mois deux mois trois mois mais
pas au-delà de 4 mois parce que on suit
la Constitution nous pouvons retarder
les élections pendant ce délai qui est
prévu dans la Constitution parce que la
Constitution dans son article 75 il dit
en cas d'empêchement
pour
comment dire le poste de président de la
République
il est tenu de remplacer ce président
par le président de la
comment dire le président du Sénat il a
trois mois pour organiser l'élection si
dans trois mois il n'arrive pas on lui
donne encore un mois donc 4 mois donc
des élections au plus tard en avril 2024
au plus tard parce que la Constitution
permet si les élections ne sont pas
organisées s'il y a empêchement que le
président partent ils partent monsieur
Tshisekedi le 23 janvier
2024 à minuit il doit partir et là on
peut regarder et voir ce que dit la
Constitution le président du Sénat
est-ce que nous sommes d'accord avec le
Président si oui ok sinon on s'organise
pour mettre quelqu'un de neutre
quelqu'un qui vient de la société civile
pour utiliser cette possibilité
constitutionnelle si dans trois mois on
organise c'est bon sinon on donne un
mois de plus et 4 mois au total on
organise les élections présidentielles
et législatives nationales pour les
Congo alors vous dites que la CENI n'est
pas indépendante et du coup pour
l'instant votre partie est Sidé n'a pas
envoyé de représentants au bureau de la
CENI mais est-ce que c'est pas
contradictoire Martin Fayulu de
boycotter la CENI et de ne pas boycotter
les élections non on oublie pas la CNI
comme on ne peut pas boycotter les
élections nous n'avons pas envoyé nos
représentants à la CENI parce que nous
ne sommes pas convenus sur le règle du
jeu nous ne sommes pas convenus sur la
loi portant organisation et
fonctionnement de la CNI donc nous ne
pouvions pas envoyer nos éléments on
nous a pas demandé d'envoyer les
éléments c'est pour cela nous vous
renoncez vous renoncez
on ne renonce pas c'est pour cela nous
disons que il faut que toutes les aussi
prenante ses voix se rencontrent et
discuter n'a pas beaucoup il y a l'union
sacrée il y a le FCC il y a la moka et
la société civile ces quatre-là doivent
se voir pour récomer la CNI premier
sujet de revoir quelques articles de la
loi électorale 3 fixer les calendriers 4
parler de la sécurisation des élections
et 5 voies comment faire avec la Cour
constitutionnelle comment recomposer la
Cour constitutionnelle et 6 voir tout
autre élément tout autre élément qui
concerne l'organisation des élections
c'est beaucoup de conditions donc vous
êtes en tout cas pour le moment
officiellement candidat pour 2023 vous
parlez
à longueur de temps des échecs multiples
de Félix Tshisekedi mais bon la
croissance est à 7% le FMI a accordé un
prêt de 1,5 milliards de dollars l'an
dernier les rentrées budgétaires d'après
le ministre des Finances les rentrées
d'impôts pardon on doublait en 4 ans
c'est un bilan honorable quand même sur
le point économique les rentrées
d'impôts ont doublé c'est pour payer les
politiques pour donner 21000 dollars à
chaque député pour s'enrichir et remplir
des comptes à l'étranger les
rentrées sont là pourquoi l'armée n'est
pas équipée pourquoi l'armée n'est pas
renforcée pourquoi on ne prend pas
d'autres congolais qui sont en âge et
qui peut combattre les former rapidement
l'entrée de l'argent dans les caisses de
l'État pourquoi il y a toujours la
misère du peuple la croissance est dû
vous le savez à cause des milliers mais
cette croissance est-ce que cette
croissance profite au congolais et comme
on dit au Congo est-ce que le panier de
la ménagère
reflète cette croissance non la
croissance pour l'enrichissement de
Monsieur Félix Tshisekedi et de ses amis
la croissance c'est pour en tout cas ces
entrées c'est pour le vol des gens
aujourd'hui ils ont mis encore un
comédie au ventre en vente aux enchères
le 23 bloc pétroliers tout ça c'est pour
des gens qui n'ont jamais été préparés
pour gérer l'état mais qui ont été
préparés pour chercher comment
s'enrichir il y a quatre ans vous étiez
vous n'étiez que deux grands candidats
dans l'opposition vous étiez le
principal candidat l'année prochaine
Martin Fayulu il va y avoir beaucoup de
monde dans l'opposition notamment vos
anciens alliés Moïse Katumbi c'est très
probable
Adolphe mosito il a annoncé qu'il serait
candidat sans parler de Matata Ponyo et
pourquoi pas l'ancien président Kabila
une opposition morcelée dans une
élection à un seul tour est-ce que
c'était pas un scénario rêvé pour le
sortant Félix Tshisekedi kabyle ne
pourra jamais plus être candidat au
Congo je vous ai dit président élu au 5
ans mandat renouvelable une seule fois
Kabila déjà brigué son deuxième alors
mandat il présente un représentant du
FCC si vous voulez c'est le peuple qui
jugera la Constitution est ouverte le
jeu est ouvert il faudrait que la
population décide donc il faut qu'il y
ait démocratie il faut qu'il y ait
démocratie mais vous ne craignez pas
tous ces adversaires
parce que en 2018 on m'a dit voilà
kabyle a mis des moyens énormes et vous
allez être battu à plat de couture et
c'est moi qui ai battu tous les
candidats à plat de couture donc je n'ai
pas peur et j'ai confiance en mon peuple
merci Martin Fayulu de nous avoir
accordé cet entretien et merci merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis sur nos deux
chaînes France 24 et Radio France
Internationale
[Musique]